this may be the only food these children
have today
everyone is here for a free meal from
charity
with poverty soaring one in five sri
lankans are going hungry
and families stuck living in utter
misery have no way out of it
indica is trying to provide for two
disabled children
and a grandmother with diabetes
before the crisis indica worked as a
laborer she told me
now there's no work or money for either
food or medicine
and for her dinner
only a cup of tea
with no money for a bus the only way to
get home is on foot
a three mile walk
even the volunteers have gone without
food for the last few days
the un estimates 70 percent of people
are missing a meal every day
last three months none of the
politicians in the full queues none of
the officers in the fall of course so
how come there they are not there and we
are in the queue some of my friends are
there for four days who do you blame for
this sri lankan government the president
is definitely
you know responsible for the crisis that
we are in
drivers agree with that
six weeks ago they spent a few hours a
day in petrol cues
now they wait for days
without fuel they can't work
without work they can't eat
my life is very bad
very bad no money
my i have two children
are the children hungry
sometimes
one time eat
some time to time it like this my life
the rajapaksa government has racked up
more than 40 billion pounds in
debt these people blame the roger pax's
for all their problems and there's now a
push to hold them to account the supreme
court is set to decide whether it will
ban senior members of government
including the former prime minister raja
paxa from leaving the country
for years sri lanka has lived beyond its
means
now it's falling apart
in this city of never-ending cute
people are waiting for rescue
nicole johnston sky news colombo